American journalist Wolf Blitzer is the
son of Holocaust Survivors we met him to
talk about his experience producing a
documentary about the Holocaust museum
in Washington DC and his concerns about
the rise of anti-Semitism and fascism in
the U.S and around the globe
wolf you are one of the best known
journalists in the United States I think
you can probably do anything you want
why did you decide to make a documentary
about the Washington Holocaust Museum
right now at a time when there's so much
increased anti-Semitism going on not
only in the United States but indeed
around the world at a time when there's
increased Holocaust denial that seems to
be escalating people making up stories
that the Six Million Jews they never
really died that's you know fictitious
fictitious or whatever I just thought it
was important and CNN thought it was
important that we'd take a tour of this
Museum which as you know is a very
special Museum dedicated to the memory
of all those who were killed during the
Holocaust so it's it's it just felt like
a good time to do it four of your
grandparents all four of your
grandparents got killed by Germans both
of your parents are Holocaust Survivors
you have a document of your father
telling his story in your documentary
yes my dad did two oral histories
telling what happened to him and his
family in the build up too and during
World War II
the first one he did was just audio at
the U.S Holocaust Museum and that was
very powerful for me even though growing
up as a kid my older sister and I we
always knew our parents were Holocaust
Survivors they always spoke about it but
they never really went into the kind of
detail that my dad did during this oral
history and then in later years when my
mom and dad had retired and moved to
Florida my dad did a second oral history
at the U.S Holocaust documentation and
education center in South Florida and
Hollywood Florida and that one was video
and audio and I never even knew he did
that but in the course of our producers
and researchers doing work researching
the build up to this documentary that
they did on a tour of the U.S Holocaust
Memorial Museum They Came Upon This
David b l i t z yeah
that's my dad David Blitzer he survived
the Holocaust met my mother another
Survivor and they got married and came
to America after World War II
he recorded his very personal very
powerful Survival Story for future
Generations
I'm originally from Ocean which is
actually the name of the city of
Auschwitz before the war
my wife did not believe that she's going
to be able to have children after the
confrontation again but 10 months after
we were married she was that was the
first time that was the first time it
was the first time it was the first time
I learned that he did an oral history a
question and answer session a personal
testimony of his experience I learned
that he did it and it was the first time
I saw his face as he was talking about
it the the one at the Holocaust Museum
was as I said just audio this one was
video and you could see the emotion on
his face for me it was so and and the
rest of my family and I and the U.S
Holocaust documentation and education
center in Florida gave me permission to
have it the 45-minute interview and so I
shared it with my family and some
friends and it was very powerful for all
of us to hear my dad talk about his
younger sisters who were murdered his
brothers
and uh and as Mom and Dad my
grandparents who were killed at
Auschwitz it was only a few years ago
when I was in Israel covering the war in
Gaza
for CNN that CNN asked some of the
anchors to do a piece about their
Heritage their history their personal
roots
and I of course said yes and I went to
Yad vashem in Jerusalem the Israeli
Holocaust Museum and it was there that I
learned because my dad did a testimony
there as well it was there that I
learned that his parents my grandparents
were killed at Auschwitz and my dad was
from the town in German it's called
Auschwitz I learned in the course of
going there that almost every town and
Village in Poland before the war had
three names had a Polish name had a
German name and a Yiddish name your
father also says in your documentary
that the biggest revenge against Hitler
was you seeing on television being a
news reporter
you know when my dad would see me and my
mom to when they would see me reporting
for CNN on television worldwide
television my dad said this to me too
this was Revenge to Hitler that a Jewish
guy a son of Holocaust Survivors could
be appearing on worldwide television
because you know before the war he said
that could never have happened and for
him this was just a very emotional
experience every time they saw me on
television my dad said this is Revenge
to Hitler
wolf in Tennessee a Pulitzer
prize-winning novel about the Holocaust
was banned to school district district
in Texas considered Banning an adaption
of Anne Frank's diary
should we be concerned about these
incidents yes I think it's important for
every especially younger people who are
old enough to understand and know
history to learn of the Holocaust it's
it's history in Germany they teach about
the Holocaust we should teach it here in
the United States as well we want to
make sure and I was a history major in
college that if we don't learn from
history we're and including the bad
things in history we might repeat those
horrible things so it's important that
we learn about it and I'm very upset
that some school districts are saying
you know we're not going to teach about
Anne Frank or teach about the Holocaust
it's very important for the Next
Generation to know about it to learn
from it and make sure we avoid it in the
future could you talk a little bit about
the danger you see and if it's not
taught in schools here
well the danger could be God forbid that
there could be an in really a dramatic
increase in anti-Semitism and that uh
you know that the Jews are going to be
blamed for whatever problems there are
as was the case in the build up to World
War II and the Holocaust and uh so I
think it's important that everybody
appreciate what happened uh during the
Holocaust learn the lessons of the
Holocaust and make sure that we never do
that again academics and others are
really noticed that white supremacy
ideology along with anti-Semitism as you
just said has moved really from The
Fringe towards mainstream politics here
in the United States well I wouldn't go
that far I don't think that there are
some white supremacy going on I was
recently by hometown of Buffalo New York
and we're doing a piece for CNN on the
aftermath of the top Supermarket
Massacre and in doing the research this
young man who traveled from Binghamton
in New York to Buffalo 300 miles in this
social media leading up even before he
did this mass murder this massacre he
was talking about how proud he was that
he was a racist because he wanted to
kill black people he was a white
supremacist and he was an anti-semite
and it just hit me that you know these
horrible horrible traits especially on
social media there's a lot of copycats
that people are spreading all these
crazy horrible dangerous ideas it just
hit me it was very sad to see what's
going on and what do you do with the
sadness
you try to fight it you try to do
something positive and resist it and and
work and learn about it and and react
and and tell these people you know
you can't just go into a supermarket
that has a lot of black people inside
and kill and I it was heartbreaking for
me to walk through that supermarket and
and in the front of the supermarket in
front of the parking lot there's a
tribute to all those people who were
killed and there's so many of them were
elderly women grandmothers who went to
the supermarket simply to buy some food
for their families and their children
and grandchildren and this guy walks in
that starts shooting these people simply
because they're black and it's just it's
just you know an awful situation
horrible
both during the documentary I had the
feeling you paused when we saw these
piles of shoes uh
what really kind of moves you or moved
your most when you walk through the uh a
museum well that was one of the moments
that really moved me because having lost
all four of my grandparents during the
Holocaust my mom my mom's parents and my
dad's parents all four of them were
killed during the Holocaust my dad's
parents at Auschwitz and my mother's
parents at a slave labor concentration
camp Chicago in Poland and I went to
Auschwitz and I went to Chicago
and you know I walked around I tried to
appreciate what was going on but over
these many many years
uh I always wanted to touch and feel
some remnants of my grandparents I'm now
a grandparent and I have a grandson and
I know what it's like to be a
grandparent but I grew up without any
grandparents and I really don't have
anything that they left behind when I
saw these shoes I said I wonder if maybe
a pair of shoes are for my grandmother
or my grandfather I would have liked to
have had some tokens some some
representative of my grandparents which
which I don't have
and here we are 77 years later a child
of a of Holocaust survivors in the
German
journalist after World War II uh when my
mom and dad were liberated from the
concentration camps they did what all
the Jewish survivors did they
immediately started traveling to see who
who lived and who died who who survived
there's no and you know you couldn't go
online or anything like that and they
would travel and they would try to find
out if their brothers their sisters
their parents their grandparents uncles
aunts who was alive and that's where my
mom and dad met because they were
roaming around the and they they met in
in Poland but they wound up in Germany
they thought there were some
opportunities in Germany and they wound
up in Augsburg Germany that's where you
were born that's where I was born and my
sister my older sister was born in
Augsburg too and my dad often told the
story to me and others that one day he
was a nearby Munich which is not far
from Oxford and he sees a long long line
he said in those days after the war you
see a long line you go wait in line
there must be something good at the end
of the line if all these people are
waiting in line so he went and waited at
the end of the line
and after about a half an hour he said
to the woman in front of him Frey line
by the way why are we waiting in line
and she looked at him and she said I
thought you knew it he said no he said
we're waiting in line for visas my dad
said visas for what she said America
what my dad didn't know
was that the U.S House of
Representatives in the U.S Senate had
just passed what was called the
displaced persons Act of 1948 which
granted 400 000 visas to displaced
persons including Holocaust Survivors
refugees you know my parents were always
so grateful to this country for giving
them an opportunity to start a new life
and raise a family become successful and
they became very patriotic Americans in
the process
well thank you so very much and also for
this documentary absolutely worth
watching and all the best thank you
thank you very much thank you
and thanks to all you're doing